hello everybody and welcome to a Python
programming tutorial for the NLT K or
natural language toolkits module the
natural language toolkit module is for
natural language processing or NLP so
what is that so natural language
processing is the process of getting a
computer to understand natural language
now usually this is in the form of
written language and sometimes it can be
in the form of spoken language but
usually spoken language gets converted
to written language then to numbers but
sometimes it doesn't
it just gets straight converted to
numbers as well so it is the process of
converting some form of language to
something that the computer can
understand which is numbers so what can
we do with that so n LT K is actually
the first module that I ever worked with
and is actually the reason why I chose
the Python programming language because
really no other programming language has
any sort of API or module or whatever
you want to call it for natural language
processing so this here is my example
this is my personal company or business
that uses sentiment analysis which is a
form of natural language processing so
I'll just show real quick just 30
seconds some of the things that we do
here just as an example what you can do
but obviously sentiment analysis is such
a tiny portion of what all you can do
with a computer that can understand text
so for example we do sentiment analysis
for finance stuff so this would be for
stocks so we could choose Apple for
example and this is the sentiment
analysis for Apple and we can actually
see this sentiment has been going up
pretty pretty strong and today's
actually a pretty good day for Apple as
well so there's that then we've liked
politics so we measure sentiment on
political issues we've got about 50
different political issues war is the
most popular by far than NSA economy oil
immigration you just keep going down we
also have sentiment on politicians
themselves this is not just the
indicator obviously we have graphs too
so there's sentiment for Barack Obama
for example anyway so we do stuff like
that and then also we have geographical
sentiment
this is probably my favorite one that I
have so far but based on what people are
saying and where they are from I plot it
up on a globe we go basically by city so
this gets as granular as per city and so
we can do this we can get you know the
last 30 days of sentiment globally but
also we can find out what are the
popular topics that people are talking
about so for the United States or North
America rather you've got love YouTube
youtubes probably just because people
are linking to YouTube videos
Durer that's literally turn that's that
okay so people are really talking about
that right now for some reason I believe
that's the most popular thing in the
last one week right now yeah you've got
Supreme Felix but anyways you can find
out what people are talking about and
their opinion on it in via the location
so I think that's pretty cool can we do
that for other locations as well so
that's just a quick example of something
that you can do and how powerful natural
language processing can become and how
you can translate just natural language
to all sorts of things that are pretty
cool and useful so moving on we've got n
ltk org is basically where you're going
to go to acquire n lck or any
information on alt K although you don't
actually have to get it from here and
this is probably the more difficult path
that you would take to even get it so
the shorter path to getting it let me
just close the existing one and let's
open up the command prompt so to get
that what you would do is if you've just
installed Python obviously you're going
to need Python to do this so if you
don't have Python like this might
actually be a lot of people's first
foray into the Python programming
language as it was mine because of NLT k
so if it is your first you will need
Python and we don't have Python up so
let me pull up Python or click
python.org and what you want to do if
you don't have python go to downloads
and then I'm pretty sure this just
senses my operating system so you would
just choose Python 3.4 or whatever the
latest version of python is it should be
cross-compatible the only thing that
won't be is with two so please don't use
two otherwise download that that will be
the 32-bit version of
Python and that should be fine so once
you have that you should be able to open
up bash your command prompt whatever and
just do a simple pit install and ltk I
would hit enter but it's not going to
work in fact I'll show you it's just not
going to work because this is four to
seven and I have a 64-bit version of to
seven so it's going to get angry if you
are somebody who has a 64-bit version of
Python you'll want to go to that website
usually link to when you go ahead and
pull it up real quick
that is what's taking a while this
website and then you can do ctrl f NL TK
click on that and then here's your allen
ck wheel and just click on that download
it and what that's going to do is allow
you to install it with pip and if you
don't know how to install things with
pip luckily for you there's a website
for that and that's this website whoa
it's mine so he can go to start learning
here that's in the basics which is
control f4 pip and bang
here we have a pip installation tutorial
which will also cover how to install
things with NLT or I'm sorry with the
wheel files like from this website for
example so you can grab this if you
don't know how to use pip otherwise once
you have an LT k and you've got it
installed or at least you think you do
you're ready to move on to the next part
so I'm going to go ahead just minimize
this stuff because we don't need this
right now so the next step that you're
going to want to do is you're going to
make sure you can go import NLT K in
your idle or whatever IDE you use so
this is just where you type your code so
I like to use idle everyone has their
own favorite and everyone thinks
everyone should use theirs
I like idle you can use whatever you
want pycharm or whatever if you don't
know what an IDE is this is ID le and if
you don't know how to get there hit go
up to your search or start bardu ID le
and then you'll just click on one of
these this is the one I'm going to be
using it'll pop up a window like this go
file new file and this is your new
Python file then when you're ready you
can save it save it wherever you want
eventually deploy matter where you have
it but
about that later and you'll just have to
save it to run it and that's about it so
I'm going to close this because I've
already got one open whoops I guess I
hit yes and once you have yours open do
import NLT kay and let's go ahead and
make sure that works first so press the
f5 key to run it it'll save it we'll run
it it's taking a second and boom so the
import of NLT Kay worked great now what
we want to do is go ahead and do NLT Kay
download and then empty parameters run
that and you should get a pop-up window
not just this one but another one I'm
waiting for it sometimes it doesn't pop
up as it should it's not here yet but
it'll show hopefully soon yeah so popped
under here it is so this is the window
you get now if you are operating
headless so say you're operating by a
shell or something like that you can
still do this you don't actually need a
GUI or X or whatever you can still do
NLT kay download and then you'll go to
like downloads I think and then it'll be
like identifier and just type in a ll
for all hit enter and you'll download
everything if you have a GUI yours looks
like this only everything's probably
read make sure you go to all and just
download all this process can take
anywhere from a few minutes to hours
depending on your internet connection so
choose all hit download and pause the
video for now and resume the video once
you have everything downloaded okay so
once you have everything downloaded what
you're going to want to do is maybe see
like a real basic and quick example of
what ltk can do for you so NLT Kay a
natural language processing obviously is
an interest for a lot of people that you
know want to have computers to read or
understand text or speech or whatever so
what is the first step that you might do
when you want to pull apart a body of
text let's say well you're going to want
to organize it somehow so let's say
you're looking at an article on I don't
know the Wall Street Journal and you
don't know how to take your next step
well your next steps probably going to
be either separating
paragraph or even separating by sentence
and then maybe storing generally you're
probably separate by sentence and then
store a little identifier about which
paragraph that sentence was a part of
because if you if you think about it
when people write if they write well
they have paragraphs that contain you
know main ideas and sentences that kind
of back up that main idea of that
paragraph or the subject of that
paragraph whatever it happens to be so
you do want to keep that in mind you
don't want to just throw that out the
window because that you know if the
author is is a good author they're
actually doing you quite a bit of a
favor so it's not like you want to throw
that out of the window
but organizing by paragraph that's easy
you know you split by a new line or
something like that no problem
now how about organizing by sentence or
something like that that gets a little
harder so what I want to talk about is
tokenizing before we move on to the next
video but before we get there probably
just knock out a few kind of terms for
natural language processing so you have
yo seer terms like tokenizing what does
tokenizing mean it's a form of grouping
things so generally you're going to have
two forms of tokenizer x' you're going
to work tokenizer x' and then you're
going to have sentence tokenizer x' and
what they do is a word tokenizer just
separates by words sentence tokenizer
separates by sentence easy so just keep
that in mind that's what tokenizing is
you're also going to hear terms of
lexicon and corporals what the heck so a
corpora is just a body of text so think
about a corpora might be a body of
medical journal journals so example
would be medical journals so this is
kind of like it's a body of text where
they're all kind of around the same
thing so you might have medical journals
you might have an example of maybe
presidential speeches was another one
stuff like that
we've got lexicon and also a core probe
would be anything in the English
language that's another example of a
corpora then you've got lexicon and look
Scott you can just think
lexicon like a dictionary okay this is
the words and their meanings now again
this varies right so for the English
language that would be like the English
dictionary but consider for example the
difference between investors speak and
regular English speak okay so the
difference we can see with someone who
is a a bull versus someone who is a bear
right so let's say investor speak bowl
investor speak bowl equals someone who
is positive about the market right
that's a bowl some bullish on the market
as opposed to you know English speak
which is just the general English
language that Bowl is you know scary
animal you don't want running at you
right that's a bull so keep that in mind
the difference between corpora just a
body of text lexicon is the words and
their meaning basically and then as when
you convert two numbers words and their
and their values so those are some words
let's talk about tokenizer z' for now
and then we'll conclude this video so i
just want to show you a real quick
example of something real basic with NLT
k yet extremely powerful and valuable as
well so let's get rid of this NLT k
download nonsense and first we're going
to say uh we're going to do from NLT k
tokenize we want to import the cent
tokenize in word tokenize you might be
able to guess what these do okay so
let's just come down here I'm going to
leave these just for the record I always
post all of my code online so you'll be
able to find the code here by going to
Python program Internet dashboard data
analysis and NLT kay it'll be right here
this is the older version of NLT Kay I
did have a series on NLT Kay long ago is
filmed with potato and it needed to be
updated very badly so here it is
so you'll be able to find it here
anyways whenever this is live I also
post all the source code on github slash
Python programming so plenty of options
for you and obviously if you're falling
behind or have questions you can always
post on the video anyway moving on I'm
going to leave this here just for the
sample code purposes not everybody
watches the videos so let's say we have
an example text and this is going to be
a sentence so our group of sentences
will be something like hello there how
are you so if I was to ask you first of
all to separate this sentence by word
how might you do it well most people are
gonna be like okay that's simple uh
we're going to just separate split by
space right that's good enough that
would split every single one of these
words and then if we said um let's see
how are you doing today the weather is
great and Python is awesome okay and
then let's say let's do the sky is
pinkish blue you should not eat
cardboard ok so now how would you
separate so you've decided you're gonna
separate words by a space ok that's
pretty good
probably like 85% accurate now what
about splitting up sentences well you'd
say probably okay that's easy enough
we're going to use punctuation followed
by a space followed by a capital letter
that's pretty good too but what if we
had something like this hello mr. Smith
we've got punctuation space capital that
is not a new line or a new sentence
rather so things like this are going to
trip you up really fast now of course
you could build a pretty good regular
expression to split by sentence and
split by words but it would be a pretty
significant one to get as much as an Tek
is going to get so that's basically how
n LT K does it so we're going to utilize
n LT K to split this by sentence and by
word and at least show you how powerful
n LT K is and save you like hour
years of riding around regular
expressions okay
so first let's do by sentence so let's
print sense underscore tokenize and we
want to sent tokenize example text so
I'm going to copy and paste example text
right in there
so let's print that okay and it creates
a list okay so this is just denote
denoting that this is a Python list so
the first element hello mr. Smith how
you doing today so it did not fail or
fall for this right and it captured
everything awesome so then what if we
wanted to do by word okay so now we can
do print word underscore tokenize
example texts we'll leave the other one
there it's fine to leave it there now
you can see it split it by word and
again it left mr. period as its own word
entirely because as you'll see it
actually treats punctuation as its own
board you can do away with that if you
want by default it recognizes
punctuation as its own kind of meaning
so it's going to split that but as you
can see it did not do it there as a
successful catch otherwise it splits
everything as you might expect now this
is again a Python list but of course if
you wanted to reference
individual elements you could do
something pretty simple so if you want
to comment out a block of text it's
really simple highlight everything alt 3
if you're an idol anyways and that will
do it now what we could do is we could
say 4 5 in and we'll do word tokenize
we'll just say it will highlight this
copy paste for I so for each element
basically in word tokenize example text
print I save it run that and I've got a
nice output hello mr. Smith how are you
doing today and so on ok so um those are
just some real quick example of how we
can begin to pull apart text and even
sentences and then obviously like I said
paragraphs it's not really so necessary
to tokenize by paragraph because it's
really simple to tell what a paragraph
is but telling sentence
is not so easy and telling words
surprisingly enough not so easy now of
course this is just the real basic stuff
this is more of pre-processing of
anything rather than any sort of
analysis or anything like that but as we
go on we'll see that NL CK can do really
powerful things like part of speech
tagging where it recognizes what part of
speech things are and all that it's a
lot more complex these are things that
you probably wouldn't be able to do even
in a few hours with regular expressions
so that's we're going to start talking
about the only other thing I will
mention is that tokenizer x' we'll talk
a little bit more in one of the next
videos maybe the next one about some of
the various forms of tokenizer x' so
there's more than just this basic scent
tokenizer there are some more advanced
ones where you can actually use
unsupervised machine learning built into
an LT k you don't even know how it works
you just use it to make your own
tokenizer is entirely based on your
fancy word corpora so that's that the
only other thing I will say too is on CK
by default works with the English
language for the most part but it
actually does work with other languages
so if you're looking to do this with
Spanish or whatever else look into it
because it probably is included with NL
CK it's not probably not going to be as
built up as the English language is but
the other major languages are actually
pretty well built up so make sure to
check that out and if not they can be
because there are trainers and ltk
trainers for just about anything you
could make your own language training
ltk to it and it would work so anyway a
little bit long for the first video most
videos won't be this long but I did want
to give you guys at least a quick taste
of the power of nl t cane really you can
utilize this power in about three or
four lines and see how how incredible it
is already so I think it's really cool
so there's a lot of cool stuff coming as
always if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time